black creators are going viral it was
not supposed to happen on purpose
and one house in atl is staking its
claim in the influencer game
the collab crib get ready for an
exclusive tour of the home we're the
girls with actress queen camara
i've been doing social media for like a
very long time and like
dubsmash take time youtube instagram
caitlyn castle a singer from bermuda i
want to dribble and dabble in like
new fashion and dancer slash actress
k'shell dabney from baltimore maryland i
want to be a movie he's going to be in
tv series and stuff like that
everybody always want to know what we
got going on and now a new crib
hey e.t it's the ladies of the collab
crib and today we're bringing you into
our world as black creators on tick tock
[Music]
hey ladies y'all looking good
girl group over here all right
yes so we know
you are creators who are part of the
collab crib but tell us about yourselves
individually we'll start with uk
show what are your dreams what are your
hopes i want to be in movies i want to
be in tv
i want to be like in like tv series and
stuff like that
but yeah i do tick tock instagram
youtube so like the whole social media
thing
i ain't never seen two pretty best
friends thanks
ugly it's a video you ain't never seen a
video before no cuz you over here
talking about some facts who ugly it
ain't me it ain't me
wow so i'm the ugly friend y'all think
i'm the ugly friend okay no i didn't say
that
she said that i didn't even say that i'm
stop playing my friend like
i'm an artist full-time yeah the social
media was just something i kind of just
jumped into because
it's 2021 you know like you have to
everyone has to be on social media at
this point to get the music across
hey theo you hear that bro
[Music]
yeah i want to double and dabble in like
you know fashion or
maybe you might catch me acting a little
bit or something but
the most part this is the music all
right kumara tell us a little bit about
yourself and your hopes and dreams
i want to be an actress for sure like
disney nickelodeon
perry like all of them yeah girl that's
tyler perry needs to happen right now
you're in atlanta i can see it i can see
it too
and she has 14 i know you're the baby of
the group how is that
um it's good yeah it works she doesn't
work like she's younger than us
right she works
[Music]
other than the fact that you're black
creators inside
one house what do you think sets you
apart from the other houses on the west
coast like the sway house in the hype
house what makes you
different more so our energy i know it's
hard to separate the fact that we're
black but you know black people we have
to work a little harder for everything
so we already know that we're not being
set to the same benchmarks and standards
and
as most of these other houses are on the
west coast or whatever mostly because
we're coming in at a disadvantage and
we're already under
being underpaid you know you never been
under treated as creators
so i think it's just our work ethic as
black
creatives so that being said michelle
do you feel like there's any pressure to
live up to the success
of the other houses or do you you guys
just do you
i feel like most of the most of us here
we do us because like if you're focused
on the next person then you can't really
like
be as successful as you want to be but i
mean sometimes
you know you do you know you do look a
little bit but
for the main part we just focus on us
and just make sure that we have
everything we need to be successful
here well kamyra being a content creator
it seems like a full-time job
hats off to you three what keeps you
motivated to keep the content coming
it's really just like where i want to be
in life like it's always been my dream
to do this like and my mom always told
me to follow my dreams so
it it's a full-time job um i'm gonna
admit
um but i mean if it's really what you
wanna do you just gotta be
like have the drive for it well what are
some of the issues as black creators on
tick tock
do you feel that needs to be addressed
on the platform
she can start i'm actually dealing with
one
um right my page was actually it said
banned for some reason and like before
it was banned like
all of my videos that i was trying to
pose it just kept getting like flagged
my kid getting taken down says community
guidelines and i wasn't really doing
anything like
michelle had posted the same video on
her page i had the same exact video on
my page in the state
so i don't i'm so confused i don't get
it have you received any answers
they said that it's something about my
age they say that i gotta be on the 13
and under
app but i'm actually 14 so it doesn't
really
make sense they said that i can't get my
page back and just for everyone watching
this is an issue that a
number of black creators have been
facing recently
right so so how are you moving forward
with this
camaro um i'm just going to have to
start from the bottom up again
i created me a new page no are you
serious yes like i had just hit like
400k
and it took me years to get there but
now
you know what i'm saying all i can do is
just pray and just work
is there a way that they can reactivate
it or is it
there's a way but they say
sometimes some setbacks are setting you
up so for for better things
that's that's wild all right well let's
talk about the appropriation of black
culture on tick tock
julia harmon she created the renegade
right but charlie the emilio got most of
the credit for it
so as black creators on the platform you
are obviously working very hard
and as you said you might not get the
same shine as houses on the west coast
how do you process that and keep going i
feel as if okay i do understand that
black creators are trans status
for a lot of you know the content that
is being produced on tik tok
but at the same time there's a way to
involve yourself
in someone's culture without it becoming
cultural appropriation
so how to necessarily address it
i honestly couldn't give you an
answer mostly it's kind of just like
you want people to appreciate us but at
the same time
it's a fun i think it's more in the
educational background where they
have to educate themselves before they
can
and like you know be involved it's
definitely
really frustrating i can't sit here and
say it's not sometimes it does mess with
your mental because you're like well dag
like
because you're trying so hard and you're
doing exactly the same thing as other
people but for some reason
it seems like you're being targeted or
you're being like hated or something
like that you know
but i mean the most we can do you can't
sit there and you can't like
you know dwell on the situation you
can't like beat yourself up because you
won't get anywhere so
even though it sucks the most we can do
we just work harder
so yeah pretty much yeah well they need
to come with that same energy that they
come with for us like they take our
stuff down
and then right yes
and also the algorithm issues have you
all heard of that oh my gosh
we're experiencing it right now tell us
okay so this this is about awareness too
you know the more people that know the
more action hopefully we'll be
taking so tell us your thoughts on that
and what's going on there
yeah okay so recently uh i posted a
video and it was at zero views for like
over an hour so i posted the same video
again
it was at zero views for an hour and i
posted it again zero views so then i
made a video basically explaining
like i have 1.4 million followers why is
it and it didn't say that they
violated community guidelines so i'm
like what is the issue if you're going
to do this at least explain to me what
the problem is so that i
would be able to fix it so i made a
video basically explaining how i felt
like it was unfair that
i didn't have the opportunity to show my
content
zero views so i posted another video was
like well hey you guys just go to my
instagram so you can see the video
zero views i don't understand what the
issue is and it's like if we're going to
get like
strike for community guidelines at least
have like at least be able to tell us
what we're doing wrong you know
don't just take it down like it's like
um scolding the child and not telling
them what they did wrong they're not
right so tick tock has not reached out
to you
about that as creators no and is this
something like if you're to be honest do
you think that this is just
something black creators are dealing
with um
i would say it's hard to say to just
pimping it at black
creators but to a certain extent i when
we experience it it's like
we all understand because we've all been
in that spot
yeah talking to creators that aren't
black don't
seem like i can say it does
i will say what happens to everybody but
i feel like the black community gets it
the worst
yeah honestly for sure there's research
that people have done to back that up
too
so yeah yeah that's a lot to take in
but on a positive note camara let's talk
about some
favorite black creators who are on the
platform who you might feel like don't
get enough shine
one of them will be for sure question
really
that's cute what do you want your fans
and followers to take away from your
content
um i want them to know that it's okay to
speak up for yourself if you feel some
type of way say what you got to say
yeah i want honestly i just want people
to feel inspired because
i came a long way to get where i am like
physically and mentally so if i can make
someone smile for two minutes
out of the day i've done my job yeah
yeah
and the same thing with uh caitlyn says
like
you just want them to feel inspired you
want them to feel good about yourself
[Music]
but i don't want nothing at all
everybody always want to know what we
got going on and now new crib
you excited don't be shy come on through
this door
let's just get into it your house is
[Music]
[Music]
we got
[Music]
shout out
[Music]
here we have our back patio we play
football
and everything out here we may get a
pool have a nice little pool party
from here you can see the back of the
[Music]
house
[Music]
up here we have a little balcony to a
room that we have i think that's a nice
feature
this is kamara's girl cave where she is
so we already have like just a little
couch you know
saying a little tv i'm trying to get it
put up on the wall at this moment but
this is where i just sit here edit come
up with content
yes slovak these are our beds
this is my side that's my size chico
yeah that's chica he be chilling
so over here is where we edit and i'll
be like okay friend oh hey friend what's
your evidence
okay
oh we have double scenes since this came
inside this is
my side and then we have a tub like i
said everyone doesn't have a shower
but it's so nice if you get to the base
it's like
but i feel like we need a little girl's
touch to the house for sure
like a little glitter little little wall
maybe
[Music]
thank you entertainment tonight thank
you it was nice having you but you got
to go now
see you later bye
tomorrow
hey ep it's the ladies of the collab
[ __ ] and today we're going to be
reacting to some of our best tea tops
we're about to take a look at your first
tic tac we'll start with you camara
[Music]
watching the video what what thoughts
are going through your head right now i
look super
young at that time i was like 11 like i
think i was like 12
i was very young i look very young who
came up with the idea to pull you out of
frame like that
um me i've seen the challenge going
around and i was like you know what
might as well just hop on it yeah so
you've been doing this thing since you
were 11 girl
yeah well i eventually i started out
modeling but i got into
like other things just started doing
skating
yeah is it ever hard for you you all to
watch back your content
cause the way myra was over here
squirming
it is yes to be cringy well let's look
at yours kailyn
what are you doing act normal it isn't
normal it's a video where
this is the boomerang i'm gonna rank
myself and [ __ ]
who's this man that's my reign
byron was he your boyfriend um
yeah he was oh okay so what went down
yeah like we used to do i used to sing
and he would rap
in videos he wasn't good at it but i was
good
and they kind of we used to just go
viral all the time
and i love that do you guys still
talking now
yeah we're still we're still like best
friends all right okay
let's move on to yours
are you ready sure
where who
you been where where who
for real okay miss actress you
definitely gave us the acting shots
when i first got on tick-tock and i seen
the audio i kept seeing people just
doing the regular stuff and i'm like nah
i like to be different so i'm like let
me act this out because when i heard it
i imagine like my mother
you know beating me when i come in the
house so i was like happened to you
before
huh this from experience yes from
experience
and i actually had my cousin on the
couch watching me he didn't know what i
was doing he was like because i kept
getting
up and changing outfits kept changing my
office he was like what are you doing
and that that's like watch my tick tock
tick tock yeah okay well let's move on
to the top of five performing videos
of the collab chris yeah
okay this is something that i feel like
the black community definitely
this is like something that happens in
our in our household
who was the little boy that robbie was
speaking to
um his name is bad kid super marcus
and um he keith had actually broke him
over our manager
and um rob had came up robbie world he
came up with the idea he was like yo
this would be
amazing if we do this he was like all i
need you let's ride around the
hoverboard
and he'll take care of the rest so then
he's just like
i love that and robbie is hilarious oh
yeah
[Music]
we need more we need more
need more we need more
first of all i felt my mom come through
me because first thing i heard
somebody's gonna bust their head on that
floor i was like oh my
they're not afraid somebody's gonna slip
and fall and hurt themselves
uh that was the point guys we kind of
worry because like we were
like as you heard in the video we're
kind of nervous for our manager keith to
yeah yeah we were scared for him to come
in and the barber
oh yeah there's a barbie here oh my
goodness yeah
yeah so by the way yeah
it was trey by the way oh that you were
sliding i didn't want to get my messed
up so i used trees
what was their reaction after they kind
of figured out what was going on
i think they wanted to get us big we
still waiting
waiting for pranks waiting forever they
haven't really did anything
y'all are good with these prank words
was that something you already saw on
tick tock
oh yeah it was tomorrow yeah um i just
came up with it like
because i've always wanted a slip and
slide even though it's winter
like it's kind of cold outside so like
we can't do it outside
so it's like you know what let's do
still indoors on a marble floor
girl i was like i'm getting too old
because my mom definitely just came out
of me
anybody home oh everybody's home alone
the boys like the door open
so
okay so um after all the pranks you know
the boys the boys thought it would be
funny to take our door off the hinges
completely off the hinges in high
outdoor they like they took them they
took the whole door the whole door off
so after the prank we said hey you guys
can you put our door back
and they tried to put it back but they
didn't put it back right so it wasn't
shutting correctly and they they lost
some screws and they lost the screw they
lost the screws they told us that we
right so what we did was took their
screws out there they're going to
replace our door
yup okay that makes a lot of sense
because i was like okay so
what did she do when she found out the
doors were open and then we see
her unscrewing so are they are they
missing screws now
yes yes their door is hanging hanging
banging eyes
[Music]
it feels really good to just see all
that melanin
and all these black creators like
supporting one another and just in one
space
killing it did you just guys just want
to come out and introduce yourself
so that was actually valid and collab
so that is another um collab house that
our manager also manages
in atlanta another black creator house
and we were actually headed to
the poll to the polls because we did um
yeah so we worked alongside joey to the
pearls to
support john ossoff and rafael warnock
so yeah so pretty much we joined along
the whole election the senate election
and we were part of the campaign
yeah we worked hard we weren't we
weren't called for them votes okay
well what's the energy like with having
all of you guys
together how does that feel genuine
yeah i could say that which is a good
feeling yeah yeah
it's good to genuinely be around black
people that want to see other black
people being but also want to work hard